bonsoir gagnant de 7,8 lac tu nous
démarrons de cette édition avec une
image celle de la venue ce mercredi à
l'hôtel de ville de montigny le
bretonneux du président de mercedes
france il est venu remettre un don de
5000 euros à la paix hui une association
mountain qui vient en aide aux enfants
handicapés un geste l'élire
d'intégration à l'encontre de la commune
qui va bientôt accueillir le siège
france de la marque allemande dans un
mois environ en effet 750 salariés du
groupe mercedes france prendront
possession de leurs nouveaux locaux
auparavant installé art concours le
groupe des ménages dans l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines et
s'installe dans le quartier du pas du
lac à montigny le bretonneux vous avez
vu quelques images il ya quelques
instants le déménagement devrait se
terminer aux alentours du 10 juin on va
écouter maintenant le directeur de
mercedes france au micro de yolaine
thorez
là pour le moment nous rassemblons tous
les collaborateurs de trois différents
sites autour de la région parisienne ici
à montigny ça va nous changer la vie
parce que aujourd'hui nous partons de
différents bureaux individuels nous
aurons un grand espace là bas sur ces
différents étages avec plusieurs
disciplines qui vont se rencontrer pour
la première fois depuis on va dire une
vingtaine d'années on va changer de
sujet on va s'intéresser maintenant à la
culture un stage un peu particulier
danse moderne est organisée en ce moment
à trappes avec la batterie dans deux
compagnies qui est une compagnie
new-yorkaise et pendant effectivement
cette semaine de vacances de pâques les
trappistes participent à une expérience
on peut dire assez unique bonsoir fini
brandon soit vous êtes ministre
conseiller aux affaires culturelles
auprès de l'ambassade des états unis
alors d'abord pourquoi ces ateliers
pourquoi trappe
pourquoi trappe croire les était liée
d'abord
notre but en général avec nos programmes
culturels c'est d'y créer des liens
entre français et américains et ont
voulu travailler avec le baril dance
company labeyrie dance company qui
étaient fondées dans un quartier de new
york le baril a presque 35 artistes ou
défavorisé du sud ou à l'époque où il
annonça chante ses milieux de travail
ont cherché mais il avait une très forte
personnalité locale eux mais une
vocation internationale très importants
ils ont travaillé dans plusieurs pays et
on a trouvé attrape une ville où il y
avait un autre groupe de danse ont
scandé 3b
oui et j'en imad on a eu une
interdiction à la ville qui étaient très
accueillants et il était intéressé pour
ce projet de
des échanges culturels à travers la
danse danse qui est une langage non
verbal donc on traverse les frontières
s'est facilement et la danse moderne qui
est pour les états unis l'un des aspects
de notre culture on est très fiers donc
pourquoi traque parce que il ya c'est
une ville de danse aussi comme comme le
baril à new york
alors c'est quand je dis entre une
compagnie dans ce new yorkais il ya
aussi partenaire de l'ambassade des
états unis mais qu'est ce qu'elle joue
au quel rôle joue l'ambassade dans ce
projet on est les passeurs si vous
voulez une subvention en aide le
financement de projets parce qu'il faut
faire venir les artistes
cinq artistes de le groupe de la troupe
avec l'aide technique donc il ya ça mais
on fait des introductions on trouve un
lieu qui est propice qui veut accueillir
ce genre d'expérience cet espace de
création cet espace des changes et puis
on le met en place est entrée en vigueur
avec plaisir ce qui se passe c'est des
projets des 100 l'occurrence et sur la
danse ça peut être sur d'autres thèmes
qui on a des programmes d'échangés
éducatifs des projets des chances
professionnelles
dont plusieurs domaines on a un projet
de murale en public
qu'on
organise depuis plus de cinq ans
maintenant on a un projet de d'art à
paris qui est plutôt un art plastique ou
en créer une oeuvre ensemble dans un
quartier sur une place publique
la danse est très important qu'on nous
parce que comme je dise c'est une
langage qui traverse les frontières
assez facilement le théâtre c'est un peu
plus difficile des fois mais donc et la
danse c'est quelque chose avec les
jeunes où on peut créer une
participation assez vite assez intense
et c'est finalement on cherche les
opportunités pour donner aux jeunes
américains et français ensemble une
opportunité de créer ensemble et c'est
des stages qui ont lieu une fois par an
seulement avec la rue dance ont fait ça
une fois on a fait deux fois maintenant
on aimerait bien faire plus on verra
bien mais c'est une stage d'une semaine
et ce qui est incroyable c'est que ils
ont créé des groupes qui vont produire
un spectacle en fin de la semaine et
chaque groupe créé quelque chose qui est
très différent s'affaisser des stages
effectivement qu'ont démarré lundi qui
s'est remis vendredi il y aura un
spectacle samedi soir à la merise
attrape avec une première partie les
clés les élèves 1 qui viendront oui les
élèves blessés décédés spectacle qu'ils
ont créé eux mêmes c'est pas une
chorégraphie qui est donné par les
artistes et les élèves qui crée sa part
justement pour mieux comprendre la
philosophie de ces ateliers est qui et
johnatan nordveit et john sanders et le
le fondateur justement de la cause de
cette compagnie a new yorkaise nous
expliquer les fondements de ces ateliers
des six cordes dancing tonight we used
to connect c'est le programme signature
de la troupe du battery dance company et
aux ferments d'autres stages de danse
sont sont pas les danseurs et montres et
les élèves qui répètent ils sont
directement impliqués dans la création
chorégraphique
nous leur donnons le cadre du profil
puisse créer eux mêmes leur propre danse
anyone
on est là pour que chacun puisse
s'essayer
beaucoup de gens n'ont pas accès ni à
l'art ni à la danse
pensons que tous les jeunes doivent
danser
nous devons leur donner les moyens de
faire s'épanouir leur créativité
forcément d'accord
ce qui est d'autant plus intéressant
peut-être avec ce rapprochement entre la
compagnie cette compagnie yorkaise et
trappe c'est aussi la diversité
culturelle puisque dans cette troupe il
y a cinq danseurs qui sont tous issus de
pays différents il ya un danseur du
ghana il ya un danseur de la barbade qui
arrive qu'à l'origine la parade ils sont
tous américains ils ont des origines
diverses et attrape les ailes à la
communauté trappiste et aussi aux
diverses oui oui c'est l'un des aspects
qui les rapproche new york c'est une
ville très diverse bien sûr la troupe
aussi plus ils ont une expérience à
l'international dont qu'ils ont déjà ils
sont expérimentés dans ce domaine donc
ils ont une programme qui qui marche et
on peut le faire confiance avec les
jeunes comme ça et ils ont travaillé
dans des endroits aussi diverses que
l'inde il s'était à belfast avant de
venir ici ils ont beaucoup d'expérience
en allemagne et laisser ce n'est que le
deuxième fois qu'ils travailleront en
france est le première fois dans l'île
de france donc on est très fiers de
cette cette grande première qu'on va à
laquelle on va assister samedi soir et
vous pensez qu'il ya justement quelle
peut être la différence par exemple
entre des dizaines irlandais déjà
l'indien les aides françaises qui a un
rapport à la langue ce qui est
particulier en france notamment dans les
quartiers
j'ignore s'il est
la culture à belfast toit en inde il ya
sûrement des différences il ya ce monde
est différent c'est lundi débute ce
programme c'est de faire sortir la crds
et itv créativité de chaque participant
de chaque alerte c'est pas pour donner
des instructions mais pour donner une
opportunité de s'exprimer ça donne une
confiance en soi qui est très utile
plus tard ça ouvre les esprits peut-être
qu'ils vont décider d'aller visiter le
saint denis après ou
faire des échanges avec un groupe
américaine plus tard mais le plus
important c'est qu'ils ont cette vision
plus large cette liberté d'expression et
cette opportunité de créer quelque chose
de même et ça c'est le vrai but est ce
que ça fonctionne justement ces échanges
qu elle vraiment des échanges peuvent se
créer après leurs cinq jours c'est pas
c'est pas l'ombre oui je pense dans les
pays où ben laden soit beaucoup plus
travaillé il ya des échanges qui se crée
paris d'inscrire une festival de danse à
new york chaque année des fois il ya des
trucs dans ce qui vient qu'ils ont
rencontrés lors de leur voyage
dans d'autres pays quand on a quand j'ai
rencontré hier matin hollander il me
disait aussi que finalement le message
qu'il souhaitait véhicules et c'était
que tout est possible oui c'est le
passage deux et j'ai envie de retrait
américain très américain maîtresse
penser à la fois c'est quand même deux
pays qui ont beaucoup de choses
message en anglais a bien exercer le
plaisir de travailler en france et que
on est c'est pas toujours le cas avec
les états unis c'est un pays on a une
riche et longue histoire ensemble et
dont il faut en profiter et ça veut dire
qu'on peut discuter de tous les sujets
de ce monde les affaires étrangères bien
sûr mais aussi de sujets de société qui
nous concerne tous les deux donc quand
tu es quand ils ont interdit tout est
possible ça veut dire que mango avec du
travail et et d'imagination on peut on
peut aussi réussir tout le monde peut
réussir quoi c'est un vrai message
d'ouverture qui explose concrète de ça
c'est pas juste une parole gordon mais
on monte que voilà vous avez travaillé
pendant une semaine et vous avez créé
quelque chose donc c'est possible
d'accord merci beaucoup voilà nos
besoins ne sont pas tous de 7,8 d'actu
et je rappelle que ce stage dure cinq
jours ils eurent encore jusqu'à vendredi
et puis surtout il y aura un spectacle
samedi soir à la merise de trappes un
spectacle d'abord avec la restitution
des ateliers et puis un spectacle aussi
des danseurs de la batterie dans deux
compagnies si vous voulez admirer ses
danseurs américains acquis qui viennent
pour la première fois à trappes merci
beaucoup ne sont pas allés
maintenant on va dire est qu'on va à la
verrière avec les familles qui se met
aux fourneaux la municipalité ont
organisé un concours de cuisine afin de
récompenser l'équipe qui réalisera le
meilleur dessert
réalisé le meilleur dessert en 1h30
c'est le défi que se sont lancés ces
trois équipes organisé par le service
jeunesse et maisons de quartier de la
verrière ce concours incite notamment à
cuisiner en famille c'est parce qu'elle
maison j'ai presque jamais cuisiné et de
classer une chose des cuisines et
avec ma grand mère parmi les ingrédients
opposé pour cette première sélection des
pommes des feuilles de brick des
spéculoos ou encore de la crème anglaise
à chacun sa méthode mais en fait on sait
pas trop pour l'instant c'est la
profitation verra la fin
d'autres en revanche sont déjà la
recette bien en tête un millefeuille à
la pomme avec une canne anglaise et et
compotée des compactes marie va
s'adapter puis j'ai ma petite fille
qu'avec moi qui mène donc 1 pékin
bien roder l'équipe duryea de sa petite
fille dresse son dessert en premier ne
reste plus qu'à patienter jusqu à l
annonce des résultats c'est la surprise
du chef indien houria et yousra sont
finalement les gagnantes de cette
première sélection est le rendez vous
pour la grande finale le 24 avril
prochain
allez troisième volet de notre dossier
consacré aux motards de la police
nationale
une série de reportages pour mieux
comprendre de ce métier ses différentes
facettes le thème de cet épisode
d'aujourd'hui les patrouilles banalisés
alors vous ne voyez pas leur uniforme et
eux ils voient tous anthony rech aux
commentaires je tends wiedemann aux
images et sons une fontaine fonteilles
au montage
en apparence cette moto semble comme les
autres pourtant son conducteur et son
passager sont en réalité deux officiers
de la police nationale en tenue civile
ils se fondent parfaitement dans la
circulation et effectué une patrouille
dit banalisée passant inaperçus aux yeux
des automobilistes surtout lorsqu'ils
sont en pleine conversation téléphonique
le message de cette mission est claire
un contrôle de police peut avoir lieu à
n'importe quel carrefour dans n'importe
quelle rue monsieur bonjour c'est la
police nationale vous présenterez votre
permis de conduire et la carte grise du
véhicule s'il vous plaît ce motards
roulent avec des pneus totalement lisse
avec une chaussée humide au moment de
notre tournage il risque la chute à
chaque écart jeu indulgence avec la
sécurité on ne peut pas être indulgent
avec la sécurité
2013 une mauvaise année pour les motards
c'est pas dû aux fautes des autres
automobilistes c'est dû au fautes d
des motards parce que il se comporte mal
aux équipes pas bien leur moto comme par
exemple aujourd'hui bas folle avec nos
listes de choses comme ça pour éviter
l'accident il faut s'aider déjà dans ce
type de cas la loi prévoit
l'immobilisation du deux-roues
conciliant les brigadiers les seront
finalement repartir ce motard avec une
amende de 90 euros en espérant que leur
message est été entendu c'est la crise
qu'on ait réuni recul au maximum les
limites de l'équipement de leur 1ère
victoire en moto ou en voiture mais bon
en moto d'excellence avis
ça pardonne pas pour quelques rues plus
loin arrêtée à un feu rouge aux abords
d'un an points les policiers surprennent
un automobiliste au téléphone
présentement votre permis de conduire
souplet carte grise je la fasse quand
vous mettez votre ceinture
du coup vous allez vous faire contrôler
en plus vous avez pas vous pape est
forcément cet usager avait ses deux
téléphones sur les genoux
les brigadiers l'on veut regarder vers
ces écrans juste avant l'interpellation
le téléphone c'est une infraction aux
récurrentes c'est vrai que
l'automobiliste
ont du mal à s'en passer contre si
l'efficacité d'une patrouille banalisée
ne fait aucun doute les policiers
doivent parfois faire face à des
réactions étonnantes des usagers sont
surpris bien sûr plus que quand on est
en tenue et bien sûr leur comportement
différents un petit peu moins de respect
on peut constater
des gens simplement respectueux
de voir des policiers en civil que
de voir des policiers en tenue en deux
heures de patrouille les deux brigadiers
ont contrôlé cinq personnes pour usage
de leur téléphone portable au volant
que l'actuel terminé merci de votre
attention tout de suite dans quelques
instants vous retrouvez claire cambier
pour l'émission économie donc pour ce
nouveau numéro il sera question bien
entendu du marché de pâques et de la
rencontre avec une chocolatière designer
bonne soirée